good evening and welcome to the 84th
Annual Academy Awards I'm your host
Daniel Tosh you may know me from such
films as the love guru and that's it
sorry if I don't hit my marks tonight
Brett Ratner told me rehearsals are for
homosexuals Eddie Murphy couldn't be
here because he's busy getting blown by
a transgender prostitute I'd like to
thank George Clooney for taking a break
from screwing every cocktail waitress in
town to be here tonight the Academy must
be honored let me smell your finger
George no woman's ever good enough for
you but apparently the script for the
men who stare at goats was nice to see
Meryl Streep yes she is one of the great
acting talents of our time just imagine
what she could have accomplished if she
were pleasant to look at
nighties you were looking as gorgeous as
you can at this point you're like what's
nominated tonight Jay Edgar who would
have guessed a movie about the head of
the FBI set in the 30s would have been
boring my favorite part was when the
ladies sitting in the row behind me made
a phone call you're 81 Clint Eastwood
the only thing you should be directing
is your nurse to give you another
spoonful of applesauce whose idea was it
to cast Leonardo DiCaprio as a fat bald
old man he looks like a 14 year old boy
I feel like I'm committing a crime when
I'm masturbating to him and now a song
yes good